During an evening out while you are looking for love, nothing is better than the help of a friend.
Also known as a 'wing man' or 'wing woman'. The name comes from jet pilots ...
... where it is the wingmans work to guarantee support and security for the pilot. The same dynamic ...
... applies when a friend helps another friend to approach a potential partner. But what is the ...
... science behind this strategy. And does a wingman actually work?
Let's start from the beginning. You look better in a group than alone. A study has ...
... let candidates evaluate photos of 300 people and found that faces are a lot more attractive ...
... were in a group than when they were alone in the photo.
Another good tactic that a group can use is that of a wild turkey.
Wild turkeys approach women in a 'coalition'. Of these, 1 is dominant and the other turkeys ...
... are helpers. These aids have less colored feathers, so that the dominant turkey ...
... looks a lot better. This strategy almost doubles in success compared to ...
... with turkeys that go hunting themselves.
Even male fireflies work together to attract women. Fireflies use bioluminescent ...
... flashing signals to get a partner's attention. If all males blink the same, the females respond ...
... 82% of the time. Compared to 3% if they do not blink synchronously. So maybe ...
... it's time for your group to think about a group dance?
Certainly if you are the wingman of a Lancetmanakin. Males of this species of birds make groups ...
... with which they perform complex dances and jump over each other. But in the group ...
... there is an Alpha and a Beta bird. The Beta never bite. So why would you want to be a wingman?
A study that examined the DNA of 457 birds, learned that the Beta birds, following the example of the Alpha ...
... had a higher chance of becoming an Alpha the following year.
This strategy is widely used among men. But what about women?
In many cultures, women are more selective and picky than men when it comes to partnership.
So there are larger variations among the sexes. Because women spend much more time, for example ...
...pregnancy. That makes it important that they select their partner more wisely.
When asked, the researchers found that more women were using the joint strategy ...
.... then apply men. But this technique is mainly used to reject men where no ...
... is a romantic interest. Again, this varies from person to person and these investigations were ...
... only focused on heterosexual behavior.
How far will your group go for you? Are they willing to lie? It turns out that the closer you are ...
... bond with someone, the sooner they tend to lie to make you look better.
That is why it is best to go out with your very best friends to come across better.
If you are looking for love or a one-off thing when you are with friends, it is fun and often effective.
But remember that finding romance does not have to be a strategic game where you are fooling someone ...
have to take. If you are just yourself, you are more likely to find someone who likes you ...
... for you.
Then to audible to help make this episode possible by giving you a 30-day trial
audible.com/asap. This week we want the book "The Invention of Nature" from
Recommend Andrea Wulf. A fascinating research about the relationship between environments of the world ...
... and the connection with people. You can find the 30-day trial at audible.com/asap
and choose from the huge selection! We think they are great for on the road.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!